creo que en el vídeo pasado les cause
algo de confusión acerca de todo esto de
los bienes por lo tanto he decidido
hacer un segundo vídeo acerca de los
bienes normales y los bienes inferiores
en esta ocasión tengo tres tipos
distintos de automóviles porque la vez
pasada ustedes me comentaban que un
automóvil no es un bien inferior sin
embargo yo no dije que un automóvil era
un bien inferior yo lo que me refería es
que el automóvil más barato del mercado
es un bien inferior porque al final en
la mayoría de los países se necesita
comprar un automóvil para poder
trasladarse de un lugar a otro esta
línea va a representar a la población
total que existe en tu país o mejor aún
vamos a suponer en alguna ciudad en
donde todos necesitan un auto para
desplazarse y bueno vamos a decir que
con el color azul voy a representar a
este automóvil ahora hablemos del
segundo automóvil y voy a suponer que
más gente tiene este automóvil porque es
un sedan y este automóvil tiene mayor
comodidad está más grande tiene una
mejor ingeniería es más seguro y por lo
tanto la gente prefiere comprarse un
automóvil sedan
por lo tanto voy a suponer que este
color magenta me está hablando de toda
la gente que tiene un automóvil de clase
media y bueno para finalizar les
presento a este auto de súperlujo un
rolls-royce este automóvil es súper caro
pero también es de lujo por lo tanto muy
poca gente tiene este automóvil y por lo
tanto ya podemos identificar que esta
primera parte habla de la gente que no
tiene tanto dinero de bajos recursos o
la gente pobre mientras que del otro
lado tenemos a la gente que tiene un
puente dinero es decir a la gente rica y
bueno lo que hablábamos en el vídeo
pasado era ver qué es lo que pasaba con
la curva de la demanda cuando nosotros
cambiamos el ingreso ahora nuestro
primer escenario va a ser pensar qué es
lo que va a pasar si el ingreso aumenta
entonces como el ingreso aumenta para
todos la gente que tiene muy pocos
recursos va a tener un mejor sueldo y
por lo tanto lo que va a querer hacer es
cambiar a un automóvil un poco mejor tal
vez de la misma marca o tal vez no tal
vez desea comprar no sé una televisión o
tal vez más víveres no lo sé pero lo que
sí sé es que la gente que está más
cercano a poderse comprar una
se dan va a poder tener la oportunidad
porque los ingresos aumentaron de
cambiar a un auto sedan por lo tanto lo
que va a suceder es que la gente que
está aquí va a empezar a comprar el
automóvil que tiene el precio medio y
bueno también del otro lado la gente que
está muy cerca de comprarse un auto de
lujo lo que va a hacer es que a partir
de ahora que tiene un poco de mejor
ingreso va a intentar comprarse un auto
de lujo pero tensa cuenta que es
proporcional es muy poca la gente que
ahora va a comprar un automóvil de lujo
así que la pregunta es qué es lo que
pasó aquí si el ingreso aumenta entonces
la cantidad de demanda a quién beneficia
entonces lo primero que quiero que se
den cuenta es que la cantidad demandada
de este primer automóvil bajó ahora
desde cuenta que para este segundo
automóvil el de precio medio la cantidad
de demanda aumentó y también observa que
la cantidad demandada de este auto de
lujo aumentó también y bueno vale la
pena aclarar que estoy hablando de todos
los puntos de mi curva de la demanda no
solamente de un precio sino de todos así
que déjame dibujar te la curva es la
demanda del primer auto que es lo que va
a pasar con él con esto nos vamos a dar
cuenta de qué tipo de bien
en el eje vertical tengo el precio y en
el eje horizontal tengo la cantidad la
cantidad demandada y ahora voy a suponer
que esta va a ser mi curva de la demanda
la curva de la demanda original y bueno
como estamos refiriendo para todo precio
lo que estoy diciendo es que si yo tomo
un punto aquí en esta curva entonces
cuando el ingreso aumenta la cantidad de
demanda del primer automóvil va a
disminuir y como se cumple para todo el
precio asumiendo que es el automóvil más
económico y pese a ello no importa
porque para todo precio se cumple esto
lo que estamos haciendo es que la
demanda de crezca y por lo tanto la
curva de la demanda se va a recorrer
hacia la izquierda y bueno es importante
que te repita que estamos hablando
acerca de toda la curva no solamente de
un punto de un precio particular de la
curva y bueno también ya que estoy en
esto me gustaría aclarar una pregunta
que me hicieron en el vídeo pasado que
me causó mucha expectación la pregunta
decía más o menos así cuando la curva se
recorre hacia la izquierda la curva se
recorre perfectamente o algunas veces
cambian es decir me estaría refiriendo a
que se recuerda más en algún punto que
en otro y bueno la respuesta es
si pueden en muy pocas circunstancias
podría ser que se recorra perfectamente
sin embargo en la mayoría de los casos
cuando se recorre se recoge de una
manera distinta es decir la forma de la
curva va a cambiar un poco mientras la
curva se recorre
pero bueno lo importante es que
regresemos a este primer automóvil que
era el del precio económico lo que
estamos observando es que cuando aumenta
el ingreso entonces la curva se recorre
hacia la izquierda lo que quiere decir
que la cantidad demandada disminuye y es
justo esto lo que habíamos definido la
vez pasada como un bien inferior y ahora
si nos fijamos en estos otros dos
automóviles tengo aquí la curva de la
demanda y por lo tanto este es el precio
esta es la cantidad y esta va a ser
nuestra primera gráfica que tenemos y
ahora si cuando aumenta el ingreso la
curva de la demanda se recorre si la
derecha es decir la demanda aumenta por
lo tanto estos otros dos automóviles nos
damos cuenta que son bienes normales